espectro
recuerdo que cuando yo era pequeña me
regalaron un caleidoscopio
este juguete de madera tenía una ranura
y se veía por medio de esta ranura y a
contraluz encontraba una figura
hexagonal simétrica colorida muy
interesante haciendo
pero todavía me sorprendía más cuando
hay rotar este caleidoscopio la figura
iba cambiando pero siempre mantenía la
misma simetría
y yo del pasado desde agua como es
posible que esté viendo toda esta
asimetría en un juguete que se ve tan
sencillo como funciona
alguien muy paciente me explicó que
realmente todo esto provenía de tres
espejos colocados dentro del
caleidoscopio en un ángulo de forma de
que lo que yo veía era el reflejo de una
recámara chiquita del otro lado del
caleidoscopio
lo que veía eran muchos pedacitos de
plástico de colores que se van
deslizando pero se reflejaban en las
paredes de estos aspectos
entonces bueno misterio y resuelto pero
aún así yo yo quedé fascinada y creo que
sigo fascinada
de cómo a veces algo como una
herramienta
un punto de vista diferente una conexión
o una idea tiene el potencial de cambiar
radicalmente el cómo percibimos cómo
entendemos las cosas
esto yo lo he vivido por ejemplo siendo
estudiante de matemáticas cuando muy a
menudo me encuentro en frente de un
problema que no sé cómo resolver o estoy
leyendo un capítulo de un texto que no
logro entender
lo que hago entonces es que busco mis
colegas
les digo quieres platicar de este tema
esto es lo que entiendo estas son mis
ideas estos son mis puntos de vista
cuáles son los tuyos mis colegas me
comparten también lo que piensan acerca
del tema acerca del problema etcétera
etcétera y estas conversaciones pueden
llegar a ser tan fructíferas que
acabamos entendiendo las cosas desde un
punto de vista nuevo y muy fresco
a veces con suerte logramos resolver un
problema que no sabíamos como antes
entonces esta comunicación este
intercambio de ideas es valiosísimo en
la práctica de las matemáticas y creo
que también lo es en muchas otras
disciplinas
ahora esta emoción también la ha vivido
el verano de este año
gracias a mi este méxico que me brindó
la oportunidad profesional de trabajar
junto con
un equipo de investigación de maite de
lab llamado global ecosystem sainz amics
initiative en este equipo había
especialistas de muchísimas ramas y
disciplinas diferentes desde ciencias
sociales y emprendurismo hasta ciencias
de la computación
análisis de datos teoría de grafos
entonces ustedes se preguntarán que que
trabajaban entonces personas de
disciplinas tan distintas
el objeto de estudio uno de los objetos
era estudiar analizar y comprender cómo
se desarrollen los ecosistemas
económicos alrededor del mundo
con el enfoque en particular de ver cómo
promover la colaboración la innovación y
la generación de impacto positivo social
y económico
esto es una línea de investigación super
interesante que se ha desarrollado a lo
largo de varios años pero también es
bastante innovadora
y han recuperado muchos datos alrededor
del mundo en muchas ciudades de muchas
bases de datos para llegar a modelos que
se ven como este
entonces a este punto casi seguro
algunos de ustedes ya ya no están
pensando que esto se ve muy intrincado o
que simplemente no hace sentido contar
tantas cosas juntas
afortunadamente si hace sentido y todo
parte de una idea fundamental muy
interesante que va así no hay ecosistema
económico que pueda separarse de su
ecosistema social cada uno es una parte
integral del otro así como cada uno
influye en el otro
y ahí es donde entran las matemáticas
ahí es donde entra la teoría de grafos
o sea no mencioné que lo importante
realmente que las cosas están conectadas
y eso es lo que modela el objeto
matemático que es un grafo
dicho muy coloquialmente un grafo son
bolitas y palitos
un poquito más claramente lo que lo que
tenemos es un conjunto de vértices y a
veces algunas parejas de los vértices
están conectados
por medio de aristas
a veces podemos tener una arista oa
veces podemos tener varias
a veces podemos tener muchos más aristas
en una configuración super intrincada
como la que vemos aquí
entonces al pensar en una estructura así
lo que le sigue es curiosidad ganas de
describirla
y ganas de comprenderlo un poco mejor
por ejemplo aquí lo que tenemos es un
grafo con ocho vértices imaginemos que
cada uno de ellos representa un lugar
una locación geográfica y cada arista
representa una vía de transporte
entonces en particular
lo que podemos ver es que no hay ninguna
forma
del punto a al punto b
al menos no con las aristas que tenemos
en este momento
entonces ahí podemos llegar y decir a
ese grafo el disco nexo
esa es una observación cualitativa su
contraparte sería una observación
cuantitativa como éste graf o el disco
nexo y tiene tres componentes conexas
a veces también queremos describir al
graf en su totalidad pero a veces
queremos escribir de manera un poco más
granular qué sucede con cada vértice por
ejemplo podemos observar que del vértice
b salen dos aristas o llegan dos aristas
entonces ahí diríamos que el vértice el
bne tiene grado dos
entonces bueno creo que el concepto de
grafos está bastante bonito bastante
claro pero no se queda sólo ahí va más
allá
y esta es esta curiosidad que tenemos de
describir los grafos también la tenemos
para hacer aseveraciones acerca de ella
para comprender cosas acerca de ellos y
ahí es donde surgen ramas de las
matemáticas tales como tierra de ramsay
teoría de grafos extrema les incluso
combinatoria enumerativa es un punto de
inspiración de muchísimas matemáticas
muy bellas y muy interesantes
y los grafos no se quedan allí también
son una herramienta esencial con
muchísimo potencial en otras disciplinas
por ejemplo en las ciencias
computacionales muchos de los algoritmos
que se han desarrollado para que
utilicen los dispositivos con los que
están viendo este vídeo han sido
desarrollados por medio de modelos
matemáticos tales como grafos
o también a veces los grafos sirven para
modelar sistemas biológicos sistemas
epidemiológicos como quizá en los
últimos meses han visto modelos del
esparcimiento del coronavirus
también los grafos sirven para entender
sistemas sociales y en particular lo que
estábamos estudiando en este proyecto
era un sistema social
y como sistema social tenía también un
propósito
el propósito era la colaboración la
generación de innovación de soluciones
nuevas
y entonces de acuerdo la tira de mí dos
éste
cuando tenemos un grafo hay cosas que
nos interesa comprender acerca del
modelo para describir que también el
sistema está desempeñándose o
acercándose a su propósito
y estos son tres aspectos tenemos a
colabora tividad
la resiliencia o resistencia al colapso
y el potencial de fomentar conexiones en
un futuro de fomentar interacciones
entonces ahí es justo donde entra lo que
yo hice en ese proyecto cuál era mi rol
pues yo era un aprendiz yo era un
aprendiz junto con kevin berchot también
recién egresado de la mitad de la
carrera de matemáticas él fue mi
compañero y también fue mi compañero en
este proyecto
y qué es lo que hacíamos todos los días
escribíamos código hacíamos una lluvia
de ideas
acerca de
exactamente quién mediciones del grafo
nos podrían ayudar a describir estos
aspectos que mencioné
esta era una era una tarea bastante
abierta había tantas formas diferentes
de
por una parte de encontrar métricas que
describieran algún aspecto del grafo y
por otra parte de juntarlas en una
fórmula
de ese modo lo que hacíamos fue
pues proponer muchísimas fórmulas
diferentes y luego las conversábamos con
el equipo y luego las validamos dentro
del marco teórico
también las válida vamos
estadísticamente y de acuerdo a los
datos que maneja vamos
y entonces lo que seguimos haciendo fue
pues descartar algunas de las fórmulas
que propusimos porque no describían
también lo que queríamos estudiar
elegir una de las una de las fórmulas
que propusimos
y pues con eso terminó nuestro nuestro
rol en el proyecto esencialmente
y vaya cabe mencionar y creo que es
bastante claro que la fórmula a la que
podemos haber llegado seguramente no es
la fórmula perfecta alguien en un futuro
seguro va a llegar con una una forma
mejor de describir las cosas
sin embargo tuvimos una oportunidad
única de formar parte de una
conversación científica con personas de
otras disciplinas que valoraba nuestras
ideas y nosotros también valoramos sus
ideas
por otra parte tuvimos la oportunidad de
ver cómo lo que aprendimos en
matemáticas en teoría de grafos también
en computación podía podría servir para
estudiar y comprender y analizar el
mundo que nos rodeaba
entonces toda esta experiencia en
englobando la en ya pocas palabras fue
muy emocionante fue muy grato y fue una
una oportunidad que yo les invito a
todos ustedes a buscar
es decir busquen algo que les apasione
que si bien no todos hacen lo mismo que
ustedes de todas formas ustedes pueden
contribuir con algo pueden darle valor
y algún proyecto alguna iniciativa si
encuentran algo así búsquenlo busquen
participar
asimismo les invito a pensar en ustedes
como parte de un grafo como parte de un
todo muy grande que está interconectado
y que se desarrolla día con día
por ejemplo piensan entonces
interacciones con las personas que los
rodean
socialmente geográficamente
piensan también en sus interacciones con
el mundo en el que viven qué recursos
ustedes necesitan el mundo que el valor
le dan ustedes
al mundo
etcétera etcétera piensa en incluso en
ustedes mismos como este sistema
complejo de principios de ideas de
valores que día con día se encuentran
unas con otras y tienen esta dialéctica
muy interesante
por ejemplo a veces como aprendemos un
dicho y otro dicho que dicen exactamente
lo contrario
entonces
vaya
voy a irme a una firma una una idea muy
valiosa
los invito a hacer como la gran
matemática maria mira canina ves dijo me
gusta cruzar las fronteras imaginarias
que la gente coloca entre ramas de las
matemáticas es muy refrescante
hay tantas herramientas y nunca sabes
cómo funciona se trata de ser optimista
e intentar conectar las cosas así
también nosotros busquemos a través de
la vida con esa curiosidad que nos hace
únicos conectarnos con todo lo que nos
sucede conectarnos con
además personas con el mundo con todo
eso que nos rodea
vivamos con esa emoción que nos
caracteriza nos hace únicos y también
hace únicos
creo que lo que hay alrededor de
nosotros